CHAD BRUBAKER: Hi.
Let's get started.
Hi, everybody.
Welcome to keep it
secret, keep it safe
where I'm going to talk to you
about protecting the network
traffic in your application.
So first of all,
basic introductions.
I'm Chad Brubaker.
I'm a Software Engineer
on the Android Security
Team for about two
years now full time.
And I was an intern before that.
There's a picture
of me if you want.
I'll never show that again.
OK.
So what am I going
to talk to you about?
So first of all, the
very, very high level.
Like what is TLS?
And why you should use it
for all your traffic, period,
everywhere.
And then I'm going to talk
about what you actually
have to do to use it on
the client and the harder
part of actually checking
your work, making sure
that you're using it.
And then finally,
we're going to get
to my personal favorite
part about various mistakes
and misconfigurations
we've seen.
Why they happen, why
you shouldn't do them,
what you should do instead.
And finally, some time
for questions and answers.
So all right.
So TLS.
First of all, why?
So why should you even care
about making sure your network
traffic is secure?
Well, simple answer is that the
network is not to be trusted.
And this has always
been true in computing.
Like this is not new in any way.
But for mobile devices it's
actually especially true.
Because think of
your smartphone.
How many different
networks does it
connect to in a given day,
different Wi-Fi networks,
different cellular networks?
And setting up a Wi-Fi network
takes basically zero effort.
Right?
I can go down to a coffee
shop, make an open Wi-Fi called
super awesome fast
coffee shop Wi-Fi,
and people will
probably connect to it.
So it's very easy for this
to happen to smartphones,
to be on a network that
may be hostile to you.
And finally, smartphones
are very personal devices
for all of us.
Right?
They contain a lot of
your personal information.
You use them to transmit a
lot of personal information.
You do banking.
You do all these
kinds of things.
So it's important.
Now when you think of
sensitive traffic that
needs to be protected,
there's a couple sort
of canonical examples that come
to your mind that kind of get
talked about in
articles and stuff.
About obviously
sensitive traffic
that you think, oh
yeah, I definitely
don't want a random person
messing with it, seeing it.
So very basic examples.
Right?
I shouldn't be able to see
the log in for your banking
account.
You probably don't want that.
Likewise, I shouldn't be able
to see your credit cards.
If you're sending
private photos,
shouldn't be able to see that.
And not only just kind of
eavesdropping, but also
modifications.
So you wouldn't want someone
to say replace the e-mail
to your boss saying,
yeah, I can totally do
that thing you asked me to do.
And just modify that to
be like, no, I hate you.
I quit.
Don't want that.
That would obviously be bad.
Sensitive web
traffic, health, these
are sort of all of the
examples that kind of
come to mind when you think what
is traffic off my device that
needs to be secure.
OK.
But what if you don't do that?
So thought experiment that I
always hear is a food blog.
So I run "Chad's Stupid Food
Blog" full of really bad advice
about food.
Should I still
secure my traffic?
It's about food.
No one cares.
It's not sensitive.
Yes.
You should still
secure your traffic.
For two reasons, I mean,
first of all, it's 2015.
Just do it.
And second, it's 2015.
I'm done.
Secondly, even if the content
isn't directly sensitive
that doesn't mean you can't
do any bad things with it
as an attacker.
So the first and sort of most, I
guess, nuclear approach is even
completely harmless
content, say I have
an exploit for your browser.
And I'm a bad guy.
Even if the only HTTP page you
go to is my crappy food blog,
I can go, you know, modify the
traffic, inject that exploit.
And that's my route
to get on your device.
Sort of more in general
kind of modifying content
in subtle ways.
For the food blog, this
probably doesn't matter.
Change my really awful
recipe to maybe less awful.
But, you know, say
you're Wikipedia.
You know, slight
tweaks to history.
These kinds of things.
And sort of on that
front what actually
impacts developers a lot is
replacing things like ads.
So you have all these
costs for running
your servers, your
backends, bandwidth.
And you offset that through ads.
OK.
Sounds good.
That's how the internet works.
But if I go in and I replace
those ads with ads that pay me,
right, that's bad.
You're now eating all the costs.
And someone else is
actually getting the money.
That kind of thing.
And finally, tracking
and snooping.
Right?
If I'm the only person
in the world that
goes to my food blog, which is
likely true, then simply seeing
that, oh, this phone
connected to this food blog
means I know that phone is Chad.
So that's not good.
And sort of the overall goal
in general is that the network
cannot affect the security of
your device or your data in any
way.
The network can
always block traffic
and always refused
to do things for you.
But it shouldn't be able
to hurt your security
in any reasonable way.
And this is what TLS is for.
So TLS is Transport
Layer Security.
Is previously known as SSL.
So if you hear
these two, they're
sort of-- they're used
kind of interchangeably.
So the way it worked was you had
SSLv1, v2, v3, TLS1.0, TLS1.1,
TLS1.1, TLS1.2.
So it's used interchangeably.
I'll probably even
say SSL a bunch.
You know, same thing.
And it's used with any protocol.
It wraps whatever you want.
So HTTPS is HTTP over TLS.
You know, SMTP and
IMAP have STARTTLS,
all these kinds of things.
It's completely
generic to a protocol.
You can use it for
whatever you want.
And it gives you an
end-and-end secure channel
between two peers.
And you get two very important
things from that channel.
You get integrity.
So you know if anyone
goes and messes
with the data in
that connection.
You know about it,
so you can basically
throw your hands in the
air and say, I'm out.
And confidentiality,
so only those two peers
actually see the data
that's being transmitted.
Now the hard part
is often making sure
that the peer that
you're connecting to
is the peer you
meant to connect to.
And we'll actually
talk about that
later in more detail when I get
to the pitfalls and mistakes.
But the good news
there is that generally
on all modern platforms,
it's safe by default.
So you just use it.
That whole peer complexity
is kind of handled for you.
Life is pretty good.
So using TLS.
This is actually the shortest
part of this whole talk.
So if you're using HTTP,
it is actually just
as simple as rewriting
the URL to HTTPS.
And it just works.
The same standard libraries
you use, just keep working.
If you're using
an URL connection,
it's just a simple
letter replace.
And generally for most
HTTP clients it's the same.
It's just completely
transparent.
Now if you're implementing
your own custom protocol,
it's still easy but
a little harder.
So you can use, if you just use
Java sockets, you can basically
just wrap it with, just
use an SSL socket instead.
There is one very,
very big pitfall
though that you need
to keep in mind.
Is that unlike what
the HTTP clients do,
SSL socket does not check
that the host that you're
connecting to is the host
you expected to connect to.
And this is something
really important.
If you don't do it,
your connections
are completely insecure.
And I'll talk about more
when I get to the mistakes.
So here's some sample code.
The important bit is this
HostnameVerifier.verify
to check that we actually
connect to android.com
not say, evil.com.
So on the server--
now this is probably
the hard part for a lot of you.
And unfortunately, I'm going
to basically skip over it
because I have 45 minutes.
And this is a
really big subject.
So if you're setting it
up on your own server,
SSL Labs has a really
good best practice
for deployment document.
Highly recommend you read it.
And generally if you're just
using some cloud service
for your backend, everybody
has pretty good TLS support
nowadays.
So use it.
So OK.
So let's say you decide,
OK, I really want to use it.
I've gone through.
And I think I have replaced all
of those HTTP URLs with HTTPS.
But how do I know that
everything that I'm sending
is over a TLS connection?
Like how can you be sure?
It's always important to test,
especially with security code.
You want to make sure you're
actually doing it right.
And so why do you
have to do this?
So let's consider the most
obvious case of source code.
Right?
I open just a static,
https://example.com.
And I go there.
Is this over HTTPS?
Yes.
But it's actually more
complicated than you'd think.
Because what if that
page immediately says
actually the content is over
here on http://example.com?
So for the HttpUrlConnection
in Android,
it actually explicitly does
not follow as reader x.
But if you're using
a custom client,
that might not be the case.
And it's actually
a little tricky.
But that's not how
you usually use URLs.
What you'll often have
is that you'll get them
from your server backend.
So consider you have
a bunch of contacts
that your server pushes down.
And one of those things
is a profile picture.
Your data is basically going
to be like, name, Chad.
Profile picture, here's a PNG
on the internet somewhere.
And you're just going to
blindly open that URL.
And this works great on Android
like whether it's HTP or HTTP,
your code just works.
But what happens if, you know,
today when you ship your app,
it's HTTPS.
But then six months
down the line,
you're doing some
tweaks on the backend.
And you accidentally
set those to HTTP.
And you don't realize.
Suddenly all those
security guarantees
you were trying to get are
kind of out the window.
And finally, what about
the third party code
in your application?
Right?
You don't want any of
your traffic to go out
over non-secure connections.
But what about that ad
or analytics library
you downloaded?
Do they?
Do they respect that?
How do you know?
I don't know.
So what do you do?
So in Marshmallow we
added a couple of features
to help you both
in development time
and actually
released on devices.
So the first thing we have
is some new StrictMode mode
detection for cleartext traffic.
So while you're developing,
you can detect stuff.
And also a manifest flag that
lets you specify whether or not
you plan to use cleartext.
And these are not
just for HTTP, HTTPS.
This is for anything.
So first of all, the
StrictMode support.
So the goal of this is
while you're developing
and use your
standards StrictMode
stuff to detect
cleartext traffic,
notify you, crash
the app, whatever.
That way as you develop it,
you can find these issues.
And the way the StrictMode
detection works is it
actually does packet inspection
of every single connection
that leaves your UID
for your application.
And it checks to make sure that
the very first thing it sends
is a TLS Client Hello.
Basically the start of
that secure handshake.
And that's good because
it means that no matter
what your code is, it's native,
it's doing some weird custom
written stuff, it will
detect absolutely all of it.
The downside though
is that there
are some false positive issues.
Because not everything that
uses TLS starts immediately
with that client hello.
Even the most basic example, if
you use an HTTP proxy to send
HTTPS.
Still secure.
But the very first
thing you'll send
is actually sort of
the connect message.
And likewise if you have like
protocols like XMPP or IMAP.
Those actually do a little bit
of handshaking before they say,
OK, now let's switch to TLS.
And those will all get
unfortunately detected by this.
But this will let you
at least if you're
doing just HTTPS,
HTTP, this will
let you check at development
time pretty easily.
And that's great.
Sort of the next side
of things is, OK, you've
shipped your app.
But how do you protect against
kind of accidental regressions?
Right?
Like the example I had where
your backend six months down
the line starts pushing
HTTP URLs instead of HTTPS.
Sorry.
So for that we
added and manifest
flag called use as
cleartext traffic.
And what this is for is for you
to basically say to the system,
I do not intend to do
any cleartext traffic.
So if I do, please stop me.
And this is completely
best efforts.
So it's up to libraries
to support this.
As far as libraries that
support it right now,
all of your HttpUrlConnection,
OkHttp, the Apache HttpClient,
all of these support it.
Download Manager, Media Player,
things you do through that.
Unfortunately not
supported is WebView.
But if you're using those
standard libraries and you
set that flag.
And if six months down the
line you accidentally do
that URL change, those
apps, like those connections
will fail.
They'll throw an
exception, hard fail.
You don't send any traffic out
over the network in the clear
where someone could
do bad things with it.
So the question I get
quite a lot is, why do you
block traffic instead of doing
sort of transparent upgrading?
And there's a couple
reasons for this.
So first of all,
if you transparent
upgrading all of
your older devices
are basically just
kind of left out.
They're completely out of luck.
If you only develop
on a newer device,
you might not even know
that you're actually doing
these connections over HTTP.
You just see them ending
up going out securely.
And finally, upgrade logic is
actually not-- it's a big pain.
So first of all,
for non-HTTP, it
might not be obvious what
the sort of upgrade path is.
It might actually require
this protocol is just
completely not allowed.
And also, just doing the
standard rewriting of HTTP
to HTTPS might break
your connections.
There are still
a lot of websites
out there right now where if
you connect to them over HTTPS,
the connection works.
But the certificate you
get is for some random CDN
or just some complete noise.
So instead by blocking,
you'll know immediately.
And you'll actually be
able to see oh, OK, I'm
like-- you'll get the
crash notification.
You'll say, oh crap.
This is now over HTTP.
You can fix it.
And you can fix all the
devices, not just devices
running [INAUDIBLE] newer.
But absolutely every device.
And that's a lot better.
So sorry.
I need some water real quick.
So now my favorite part
because I'm a security person
are the various mistakes
and misconfigurations
that people make.
So how do you know that
you're using TLS correctly?
Well the good news is it's a
secure by default on basically
all modern platforms.
So if you don't try
and do anything custom,
you are good to go.
Life is great.
You don't need to do anything.
Unfortunately, it's
possible to override
a lot of these defaults.
And you'd like to hope
that no one overrides
these with insecure code.
That it's always secure code
that's well thought out.
But that's really
not often the case.
And so throughout
this whole thing,
I'm going to be referencing
a lot of information that's
also available on the
security SSL training article.
It has code samples
for all this.
It has a lot more words
than I'm going to go into.
And I highly recommend
you read that.
If you're ever doing TLS,
please look at that first.
Because it's a better source
than most of the internet.
So why do people put insecure
TLS code into their app?
Well the simple answer
is that what happens
is someone has an issue.
They go on a forum.
They post hey, I
have this issue.
Someone hands them a code
sample that says, yeah,
just take this.
This will fix your problem.
Copy and paste it into
the app, or run it.
Good.
Ship it.
The problem is is that most
of the code samples provided
are bad.
They fix the
problem by basically
removing all of the security.
So you'll never see that
security exception again
because you'll never see
a security exception.
And that's not what you want.
So before I kind
of go into these,
I'm to go into slightly more
detail about what checking
trust and TLS actually is.
I'm going to skip
over most of it
because it's really in-depth.
And I don't think you
need to know most of it
for the context of this.
If you want to, you
can go read an RFC.
Have fun with that.
So there's two big
parts about TLS trust
checking at a very high level.
First of all, that the
person you're talking to
is the person you
intended to talk to.
And that they have a
trusted certificate
saying they're that person.
And these are
slightly different.
So for example, I can go
when I register evil.com.
I can go buy a certificate
for that because I own it.
And that's all fine.
But that doesn't mean that
my certificate for evil.com
makes me trusted
for android.com.
Right?
I'm only trusted for that.
And likewise, anyone can make
a certificate for android.com
and say, yes, hello.
I am android.com.
Please trust me.
But you actually need to
make sure that it is trusted.
And both of these two
high level things,
there is a lot of bad code
out there on the internet that
breaks these.
So the first one I'm
going to talk about
is making sure you're
talking to the person you
expect to talk to.
Because obviously if you make a
secure connection to evil.com,
that's probably
not what you wanted
when you wanted to make a
secure connection to android.com
to send whatever user secrets
or magic you wanted to send.
And now this is done for you
by standard and all the HTTP
libraries.
Again, if you're using
a cell socket, it's not.
You have to do this yourself.
If you're not, you have
a very big problem.
So the problem that gets a
lot of people to take code
off the internet is dealing
with legacy clients or legacy
servers can be kind of tricky.
So say you have a server.
And on that server you host
a bunch of different domains
like most servers do.
You have example.com,
example.org,
and say even android.com.
And each of these has
a completely different
certificate.
And when you connect-- so you
connect and the client says,
hi, I want to talk TLS.
Please give me your certificate.
Which one do you provide?
Right?
You've got three possibilities.
You need to provide one.
Which do you do?
So the good news is
that this problem
was solved a while
ago in TLS with what's
called the server name
identifier, which basically
says in the Client Hello,
hi, I want to talk TLS.
And by the way, I want
to talk to example.com.
But you might not
always have that.
So for example,
if you're dealing
with really old clients,
you might not get that.
Or also if you're using an
older protocol like SSLv3, which
doesn't support such things.
So how do you make sure that
those connections still work?
So the right way to do this
is a little complicated.
But you basically need
to check that, OK,
I know that the
default for this server
is actually going to
give me example.com.
So when I connect
to example.org,
I'll actually explicitly
check that I got
a certificate for example.org.
Now it's important to
say that you probably
don't need to do this.
SNI has been supported
on Android since 2.3.
So if you don't support back
that far, don't worry about it.
There is an asterisk
around that,
which is that the way that a lot
of HTTP clients work is they'll
try to connect with sort of like
the most modern TLS settings.
And that may fail because
unfortunately on the internet
there's just a lot of old kind
of bad networking hardware
that chokes on TLS.
And so they'll do sort
of a protocol downgrade.
And that can lead
to you downgrading
to SLLv3 on some libraries.
And then at that
point you no longer
have the subject name, field.
So you might get the
wrong certificate.
But usually if
that happens, SLLv3
will fail as well because
you're just on a bad network.
So the wrong way to do this,
some very common advice
out there, is you replace
the default HostnameVerifier
with this HostnameVerifier
that always true.
So is evil.com trusted for
this connection to Android?
Yes.
This is kind of like
obviously bad code.
Please don't ever use this.
It's very easy to
man in the middle.
I go buy a certificate
for evil.com.
And your connection
to android.com, I just
hand you that certificate.
You say, oh yeah,
this is trusted.
So it was issued for evil.com.
Connect.
So this means that you
will connect to basically
any valid certificate.
And anyone out there can
go buy a valid certificate
for their own domain.
It's $20.
Nowadays you can probably
also just get them for free.
So even if you have
a valid certificate,
it's not just valid everywhere.
It's valid for one
specific thing.
And you really need to
make sure that's the case.
So the next thing
is actually, how
do you make sure that the
certificate that you got
is trusted?
What does that mean?
So again this is going
to a very high level.
I'm not going to go into
it in a whole lot of detail
because it's very complicated.
There's RFCs the
size of my arm you
can read if you want to
know the full detail.
But this is going to be a
very high-level overview.
So when I say how do
you verify the peer?
So what is the peer in TLS?
It's usually represented by
sort of their certificate
that they provide.
So you have some options
for how do you trust this.
You can always hard code it.
But that doesn't really work
because certificates change.
And they change very often.
For example,
google.com certificate
rotates every three months.
So you can't just say
in your application,
I expect this certificate to
be this because in three months
it's going to be
completely different.
And generally that
doesn't scale.
Like what if you're an
application that you're
like an RSS Feedreader.
And you just connect
out to the internet.
You obviously can't hard
code the certificate
of every web page on the
internet in your application.
I hope.
Don't try.
So what is the certificate?
It includes the name,
so who is this for?
It includes the public key
for the asymmetric crypto,
which you don't have to
worry about for this talk.
But crypto keys are in there.
And it contains an issuer.
And this is someone
that's basically said,
I am stating that that
cryptographic key up there
is tied to google.com.
So this would be like VeriSign
or GeoTrust or certificate
authorities you've heard about.
And it contains a bunch of
other things, expiration dates,
key usage, et cetera.
But we'll skip over those.
So the issuer itself
is also a certificate.
So it's google.com certificate
it's issued by VeriSign.
That VeriSign
certificate is probably
issued by another VeriSign.
And you get this chain.
So you have this nice change.
But how do I know if
I trust this chain?
Sort of like you
keep building this.
But it's turtles
all the way down.
If you've heard the expression,
which hopefully you have.
In the end you
still need to say,
do I trust this long
chain of certificates?
And the way you handle
it is your operating
system or your application
ships with a set of trusted
certificates.
And so these are sort of
your very top level routes.
And then you get a
chain from your server.
And your server
says, I'm google.com.
And I'm like, I don't
know that certificate.
But I was issued by VeriSign.
And so you do the look up.
And you say, oh, OK.
I actually do trust that
VeriSign certificate.
It shipped with my application.
It shipped with the phone.
So another question that
comes up pretty often,
so I'm going to kind of
detour into that for a second.
Is how can you trust
the CAs on the device?
You know, you look.
And there's 100 or so.
And you don't know
who most of them are.
How do you trust them?
This is sort of a hot topic.
So there's sort of
two things to keep
in mind when you're
asking yourself,
how do I trust these guys?
Why can I trust these guys?
First of all, they do have a
lot of strict requirements.
There's audits, et
cetera just to get
in sort of general
certificate authority lists.
Not just for Android.
But this is the
standard in the world.
And finally, not only
is it hard to get in,
but there's actually
a lot of work
to verify that no one's
doing anything bad.
So you have things like
certificate transparency
where you actually
note down what
certificates have you issued.
Or things like pinning,
so that you can actually
detect if anywhere
in the world someone
misissues a certificate.
Even if it's only used once.
And that lets you detect misuse.
And then from there
there's risks to business.
You know, all that fun stuff.
So OK.
Back to trust checking.
So the problem is
what if you want
to trust your own certificate
that the system doesn't
normally trust?
And this can be for
a couple of reasons.
Maybe you want to use
your own certificate just
for local debugging.
Right?
You don't want to
take the certificate
for your actual backend and
put it on your random developer
workstation.
That's probably not a good idea.
That just doesn't feel right.
And secondly, you might
actually just not trust
certificate authorities.
Like sure, I made a
very quick argument
about why they're a pretty
reasonable source of trust.
But maybe you don't want to.
And that's fine.
So maybe you want to run your
own certificate authority
and ship that with your
app and only trust that.
Or maybe you have
some internal network
and you issue certificates for
internal web pages using that.
And that's obviously not trusted
by the device by default.
So you need to sort of
ship it with your app
and make sure that
your stuff can connect.
So I'm not even going to include
the code for the right way
to do this because it
would take four slides.
When I tried, it's
pretty verbose.
But you can go get it off that
security SSL training article
I told you about.
It's not complicated.
It's just, it's
very verbose Java.
So I'm going to
save you from that.
But the real gist of it is you
basically take the certificates
you want to use.
And you tell the
system, OK, these
are the trusted roots
for this connection.
Connect as normal.
And that all works.
But unfortunately, the
code that you usually
find on the internet when you
search for that exact problem
is this.
And this code, this
code isn't the clearest.
So it's going to require a
little bit of explanation
because it's very verbose.
So we make an SLLContext,
not important.
We make a new X509 TrustManager.
And it has these three
methods, check client trusted,
check server trusted,
and get accepted issuers.
And then we set this as
the default socket factory
so it's used for
all connections.
So what does this actually do?
So we have this blank check
server trusted method.
What does that mean?
Well, if you go and you actually
look at the real documentation,
and you read, check
server trusted
throws a certificate exception
if the certificate chain can't
be validated or isn't trusted.
OK, so that line is
completely empty.
So it will never throw
that certificate exception.
It will always be
trusted no matter
what garbage you give it.
And that's bad.
Because that means that
absolutely any certificate
in the world is trusted.
And its completely trivial
to make a certificate.
Right?
It's just a bag of bytes.
Run it through open SSL.
Done.
Again, do not ever
use this code.
Now I have seen this in
actual production apps.
But also a lot of apps tend to
use this code for debugging.
Sort of you have this if
debug, install that check.
And that's OK so long as
you never actually ship it.
And unfortunately,
that happens sometimes.
So the better safe thing
to do is don't ever,
just don't use
code that disables
the verification completely.
That is way too big of a
hammer and way too dangerous.
For local debugging
what you should do
is again, back to this code
that I actually skipped.
Is have a CA that you
use only for debugging.
On your debug build,
put that in your app.
Trust that certificate.
Do not turn off trust checking.
All right.
If you accidentally ship
that, suddenly all your users
are now easy to attack.
And that's not what
you want to do.
OK.
So sort of lessons for you.
If you're not overwriting
the secure defaults,
there's nothing for
you to worry about.
Right?
You're good to go.
Life is great.
But if you are, some
important takeaways.
First of all, make sure
you actually need to.
Right?
So the HostnameVerification
example
at the start, I've actually
met with some developers who
said they needed to
do it for making sure
that had SNI working on
devices that didn't support it,
which was odd because the
earliest version they supported
was Jelly Bean, which
already had this.
Right?
So before you even
go customizing it,
please be sure that
you actually need to.
Because this is sort of
like the most dangerous way
to do things.
Secondly, once you've
decided that yes, OK, I need
to do something custom, Chad.
I'm going to do it.
Please don't blindly
take code samples
off random pages on the internet
without understanding them.
Especially for security
sensitive code.
Unfortunately, there's
a lot of really bad code
out there for this because what
happens is someone says hey,
I can't connect to my server.
I get the certificate exception.
And the advice is straight
up just, oh, use this code.
And you won't get the
certificate exception anymore.
Which is technically correct
because you can never
get the certificate exception
if you use that code.
But that's probably not
what you really wanted.
You wanted to fix the issue
with that single connection.
You probably are using
TLS because you care.
Right?
So please don't copy
and paste that code
without understanding it.
And for most of your common
SSL issues that you run into,
there's actually
better documentation
on that security
and SSL training
page on developer.android.com.
So really go there first
not second or last before
random forums, random
people giving you
code on the internet.
So OK.
So that's what you should do.
So what are we doing about this?
Because those bugs are
kind of embarrassing.
And they're sad.
So there's a couple
different things
that we're doing on
the Android side.
So first of all, along
with many other things
we're doing detection of
vulnerable applications in play
and actually
notifying developers
and telling them to fix it.
Not just for these bugs, but
for actually a whole slew
of security issues.
Next up, this is what I
spent a lot of time doing,
is actually tools to find
these issues in applications
and in generic devices.
There was unfortunately
a complete lack
of tools to do this
when I started.
So I built one.
And finally, investigating
APIs that make
it harder to do things wrong.
A general rule for
security APIs--
and if you ever design anything
security, keep this in mind.
It should always be easy
to do the secure thing
and really hard or impossible
to do the insecure things.
Over customization is
actually your enemy here.
So looking at things on
that to move away from these
APIs that are really
easy to get wrong.
The trust managing code
is way too easy to break.
So some notes on that
vulnerability alert
and blocking.
So if we detect a vulnerability
in your application for SSL,
old libraries, those
kinds of things,
you'll get a vulnerability alert
via the email on your console.
And you'll get a
notification on that page.
Make sure you actually go
and check these and fix them.
Because if you don't fix
them, your application
may be blocked.
Right?
Don't ship things
with security issues.
And if you, once
you go, you fix it.
You upload it to Play.
You'll basically get an
answer back pretty quickly.
And already a lot of vulnerable
applications, a lot of installs
have been fixed.
So for all of you that have
fixed things, thank you.
Please keep doing it.
We really appreciate it.
So finally, on the tool side of
things, actually a year ago now
I released a tool
called nogotofail,
which is a network
testing tool for finding
these classes of bugs
and a whole lot of ones
I didn't mention in this talk.
Basically all of your
SSL issues, not using it,
using it wrong in
many, many ways.
It's on Git Hub, google.com,
GitHub, Google, nogotofail.
And it runs on
the network level.
So it actually supports
absolutely any device.
It's not an Android
specific thing.
I've used it to test random,
off-the-shelf things just
for fun.
And it means that you
don't have to change
the device in any way.
You just plug it in.
And it actually works without
making your device unusable.
So my tablet at home
has been on nogotofail
for well over a year.
My personal phone
probably spends about half
the time on a
network running it.
And completely usable.
Like I can still
read random messages
and get cat pictures
at 2:00 in the morning.
It all still just works.
But a nice thing it does
support is if you do kind of
have the ability to
run code on the client,
there's actually this extra
thing of client attribution
notification.
Because what happens when you're
looking at network traffic
is you say, OK, I saw
this vulnerable connection
to example.com.
I have no idea what on
the phone made that.
Right?
Because you don't
want to just be
stuck with someone on the
phone made that connection.
You want to say this
app at this time made
this vulnerable connection.
So we have support for that.
And what you can
actually see up here
is an example of
those notifications
where so the test
app I basically
hit the button to connect.
And you immediately get
this notification MiTM
via SSL certification
for another host
name, which was the
first misconfiguration I
talked about.
And a connection from the
notogofail tester app to IP
port blah blah blah blah blah.
So it is an awesome tool.
I recommend you play with it.
But it does require
some advanced setup
because it does do things
at the network level.
So it's more
targeted toward sort
of people interest in security.
But if you are interested,
highly recommend it.
And it's probably-- I wrote it.
But I'm going to say it's
the best tool out there
for this kind of thing.
And I'm pretty sure I'm right.
Famous last words
on camera there.
So play with it if you like.
And with that I've got
some time for questions.
And for me to drink some water.
So there's people running
around with microphones.
So if you have questions,
I guess stand up
is what they told
me to tell you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
CHAD BRUBAKER: Hi.
How's it going?
AUDIENCE: I was curious.
If a user decides to add
to the device's trust store
with a custom root or
custom certificate,
does that make my
app more vulnerable?
CHAD BRUBAKER: It
depends on certificate.
Right?
I mean I suppose if they added
a certificate that anyone
in the world knew, yes.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
CHAD BRUBAKER: Generally
I would say no.
Because what that
tends to be used for
is sort of like I have a
corporate internal cert.
So I add that.
Or I have, I'm doing
some local testing.
I add a MiTM CA to
the device wide.
So generally, no.
I mean it's
technically possible.
But generally, no.
AUDIENCE: Is there a way for my
app to decline all like custom
and only use the trusted store
that comes with the device?
CHAD BRUBAKER: Yeah.
So already you can
specify the custom set
of trusted certificates,
like I mentioned earlier.
You can easily just only trust
the ones from the system,
if that's what you'd like to do.
You should be very
careful doing that though.
Because if you do that,
there's a good chance
that your device might
not connect again.
Say for example, they
added that testing
cert that they're MiTMing
all the connections with
to do debugging and similar.
If you don't trust that CA, that
basically means that device,
your app's never going to
succeed in a connection again.
So it's a trade-off you
have to keep in mind.
Some people have made that
trade-off for security reasons.
But just keep that in mind.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: All right.
So through the
years the WebView's
been made as a component that
you can update independently
of the framework.
And I'm wondering if there's any
plans of doing the same thing
possibly with the
BoringSSL or essentially
whatever SSL library
is being used.
CHAD BRUBAKER: So actually
that already exists.
Through Play Services
there is what's
called a ProviderInstaller,
which actually does install
the most up to date
version of conscript,
which is the library that
does all the SSL on Android.
So it's actually already there.
It's called ProviderInstaller.
I believe it's linked on the
SSL training document as well.
And it's exactly
what you asked for.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: My question
was a little related
to the question he asked
a bit ago about the user
installed certificates.
And I was wondering if Android's
doing anything to really warn
users more about that.
CHAD BRUBAKER: So--
AUDIENCE: One case I
think of is Lenovo.
They shipped with these
bad root certificates.
And then I also think about
you go to a coffee shop
where somebody has
created an open network.
And they've got like Charles
running on their laptop.
And they force you to install
their certificate to connect.
CHAD BRUBAKER: So.
OK, so a couple things.
So there is already notification
if you install a certificate.
In fact, there's a
very scary warning
that says like your network
traffic may be monitored.
We basically have no guarantees
for you at this point.
Because that's true.
For the Lenovo case
that's a little different.
Because it wasn't user-added.
It shipped with sort
of the trusted set.
For that we have CTS
tests to sort of make sure
we don't have similar
issues like that on Android.
For the final thing if
you connect to a network.
Yes, if you trick
the user or you
kind of con them into installing
a cert, that would be bad.
There is a lot of scary
wording already around that.
So I don't know
how realistic that
is of actually
convincing someone
please install my Charles CA.
But that would be bad.
We have one here.
And then one in
the back as well.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
CHAD BRUBAKER: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I just had a question
about certificate pinning.
What is your opinion about it?
With the other examples
that you showed,
there's a lot of bad examples
about certificate pinning.
And there's also a
couple of libraries
that are actually doing it.
And in the official [INAUDIBLE]
there's nothing specific about.
So-- I just want to
hear your opinion.
CHAD BRUBAKER:
Yes, so there is--
there's no current any
public API to do it.
As far as certificate pinning,
it's useful in general.
What certificate pinning is for
those of you who don't know, is
you basically say I expect
this certificate to show
up somewhere in the chain.
So that it's not just
that it was trusted by any
say on the device.
But you can actually say it
had to come from VeriSign.
Or it had to come from whoever.
Now there is some danger there
that you need to be careful of.
Is if your app has pinning
code and you suddenly
need to change your certificate,
you may break pinning.
And if that happens,
you're kind of out of luck.
But something to keep in mind.
Pinning in general
is a good thing.
I know OkHttp has APIs for it.
Yeah.
It is a good thing.
And it's something
that I support.
There are less bad
examples of code for it.
Just because there's,
I think, honestly
just a lot less
examples of code for it.
It's sort of the same overriding
the TrustManager code.
Just there's not a lot
of code out there for it.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
CHAD BRUBAKER: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I think in Lollipop
a lot of cyber suites
were dropped per
default. I had dead ones.
So much traffic to the
server was not accepted.
And people were looking at me
because the Android app was not
working.
And iOS is still working.
How can you help get
the message across
that-- well a lot of app servers
might support still old cyber
suites.
And to upgrade the
server, because I'm not
the security expert.
But when I connect to an
old server, so to speak--
CHAD BRUBAKER: Right.
So.
AUDIENCE: --people look at me.
CHAD BRUBAKER: Yeah.
So dealing with old servers.
So what you'd
hopefully see is you'll
get some SSL exception
back saying like basically
no agreed ciphers or something.
There is actually
some information
on the SSL page
about what to do.
The unfortunate thing
there is it ends up just
being like upgrade
ciphers on your server.
And that's really dependent
on like what infrastructure
are you hosting on?
I probably couldn't
give you specific advice
unless you're doing the exact
same flavor of weird Gentoo
Linux shenanigans
that I like to do.
Don't do that.
So I don't know the best thing
to do for good advice on that,
unfortunately.
I know people are
working on it, people
much better at that
kind of thing than I am.
But I don't have any super great
advice for you unfortunately.
Anybody else have questions?
Otherwise you can go get food.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Hi.
So you talked about basically
how to trust a server.
Is there any way to accomplish
the opposite direction?
How would a server--
CHAD BRUBAKER: You want the
server to trust the client?
AUDIENCE: --trust the client?
CHAD BRUBAKER: You're
in a very dangerous game
if you're trying to do that.
So I guess the first question
is, why do you want to do that?
AUDIENCE: For instance
if your web services are
intended to be public.
CHAD BRUBAKER: So for
that, client certificates.
So you actually do have
this two-way thing.
So the server gives
you a certificate.
And the client can as well
present itself a certificate.
So for that sort of
case, a common example
is sort of a corporate case.
Right?
So your IT department
issues client certificates
to all your devices.
And then when those
devices connect
to your internal servers,
they present that.
So that you can do that
mutual authentication.
So that is supported by TLS.
And it's just a case of
getting those on the device
and that kind of thing.
Question over here
in the corner.
So no one on my side?
I can't actually see over
here because the lights
are right in my eyes.
None of you have questions?
Sweet.
Hey.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So you mentioned
about StrictMode.
So I just wanted to get a little
bit more context on StrictMode
versus the TLS dependably
that you're talking about.
Because it deals a lot with
VM policies and the thread
policies.
CHAD BRUBAKER: Right.
So the main difference between
the two is kind of accuracy
and when you should
probably use them.
So the StrictMode detection
is actually much more heavy
handed.
It does IP level stuff.
But it also has this issue
of being false positives.
And generally with
StrictMode stuff
you probably don't want to ship
with it on on like shipping out
to users.
Because it does, it breaks
on things like HTPP proxies.
The purpose of that manifest
flag, on the other hand,
is something that you
can sort of safely
ship in your actual
production builds to users.
So it sort of just
differs on that front.
As far as the policy between
like thread and VM policy
you would have to
ask Jeff Sharkey
on the exact implementation.
And he's talking later.
So you should go ask him.
But I believe it--
actually I don't
know on the interplay between
those two between the VM
and thread policy.
You have to ask him.
Any other questions?
All right.
I think there is food.
And I'll be hanging out around
like the office hours and stuff
if you have more questions.
So thank you all for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]